T TO GET TIANEANPOUR, WHO  PR N.
SINT ALISTEN IN.
VERYSPNOW,
T T IN A MOMENT, BUT
M EXPECTED TO A
DECISIO LEAVE YOUR COUNTRY D BEA
THAT OTHERS DOT .
S MADE
DECISION TUR COU.>> Translator:S
QUESTI, D THANK YO.MPORTANTHE
UKRAINE, FOROM
OUCO
AR AGREE TO EVERYBODYD OU
BACK.
I DO BELIEVED S E CA,  FFERENT O
I WOULD LI T
O GER UNTRY.NO
WE'RE VERYON
WERE RESPONDG TO
INDICATIONS.R OWN VACCINALTHAT,
AS COVID
VACCINE ISEAEAWE ALREADY KNOTHID
THEY AREOT THE
LATION ON  AND RND TO. HE
WAUTE IN THIS TENSIOFOR MANY, ME
NOT THINATED T
ARE TALKING ABOUT RUIA ESON THEA
ISK
BUSHEL SO GO TO WAHILEN TH
OCAV
LONS, WEEMMEDIA,
INFORMATION.
WERVILITY, WE NEED CAL ADULTS.
FROM THI IN THESTEHE
UKRAIN--IT OF ESCALATION ON THE
SO-CALLED FA
ED ABOUTRS
SAY UKRAINIAN MINES
WE UNDERSTAND TH  H? YVEOF THE ?
VEATIONS AREVERY.AID, IHE
MOSTPLICED  CRIMELOERS  UAIND R
FOR THE 30,  ON TH
ERMPTEOR MORE, 150 ALO,  PROVENE
HAVE THER OF TROONNNON FIRE
WE UNDERSTAND WE KNOW
THE HISTOROF SOVIET IOEY DON'T N
ND ARED
LEAD TO, N
N'T TELLOU WHAT WILL
.14H MORE
NOS  HC
ITTRAGEDY, A IN THSEE AGEDY FOR
LEADH A CHAR NOW OBUT WE ARE AT.
WH WES ON THE ED TRI
THE THEY HAV THIS IS JUST N URL.
O IR UND.
THIS IS JUYNICISH A
EVT THEY ARE SOMETHING ON THEIR
SHOOTING.
ND OF CYNICISM2014 THAT THEY ARS
E T ISONS MANY
Y, AND WE HAVET
EN PASSING O ERANO E E Y TO DOWA
PLATFU AB
RE T
THPOSHOOTING
I WENT LONG
E WHENEVER YOU
WANT.
ANOWO A W DAYS AGO?I THINK EVERE
SOLITY UNITED
STATES AND YOUTRY, AND
UNITEPRESTRAORDINARY DEPARTUREE
UNITED STAS USED
INTELLIGENES PUTIN DIFFERENT TH
>> TnsULAT ON TH, UM, AI T YAT I
FOR METHE UNITED  SHOUL TIR
E DOING THISA OFESSIONAL MANNERU
GRATEFULOR BOTTHE INTELLIGENCE
EN IINLLUST UKRAINIATEIG OERRIT
WHAT'S GOIALONG OUS, WE FFT
INTELLIGT
ND RISBAAND INTERCEPTED DATA.OU
FOUSED.EDS MANY ARE N RLL I.
WE UNDERSTAND WHAT CANYBE THL
ST PURSELVES
NSTINGN SOLDIETOE INIS NAR DO.
OT GOING
ANYONE STAND READYO REN
D OFS N YO IN LY YOU ARE BEINGT?
TOLDR WILL HAPPE
NG OUT.YOU LIVE I KIN URRENCY,
COUNTRY?
NO.E O DISBALANCE OUR
WECO.E W TO
IF THERE'S A WEAARM,AN
JUAN WON'TVE PRO -
IS WHY OURES
.HINKOTACT TO WHAHAVE TS INFORM
HAPPEN TO MYEOPLE, WHAT  A
OM
THEIR DEPOSIT , AFTER
EA AND THETARTWE HAVE THE FOWA
HYBRID WAR GOING ON. ARE
FFERENT  WORD.
YOUR BESRENGTHEN OUR ECONOMYVERB
IF YOU ARE
CHP GIS GRANT SUPPORT
ENEYWH
YSNG THESE
67 ANA DOZEN OTHER
OUNTRY IN AT WOULD HAVCH
IMTITHAT IT SYWET
COUNTRY. AA STRONG
YOU TALKEDABOU -- . WANTE
AGO WITH ONE OF THERS NGSOME TIM
AND WE'RE TALKINOUSANCTION P DON
SH
ESSIONILHAWE ARE WAR
WILL START
SA, EN APPSANCTIONS TOY.S, THEY
TELLIN% YING, FINE, BUT YOU AR
THE WALLA COUPLE
ENARE YOU WAITIN
DD YOUR SANCTIONS WILLAFTEOUR N
B AFT HAVE NOER WE
COF WILL BE CUPIED.
ULTHEN?
?AS WHA DO
WELL, LETSF DIFFEREN
WE CAN THET.
WILLINES S CALLING FOR
TIS TO B TT NATO.
OUTHE BIG ISSUE.
YOU HAVE JUSLKED,
AGAIN,TING PART OFT YOT EXPE
NATO SS ON YY
AIRYW.
AT WANTING?
.IF THE WHO UND
RUN FEDERATID IFN FEDEF THEY ARL
QUONTHAT'S A SON.
C.Y PULL B, ULD BES JUSTMATICA
THE LE SANIO
EVEN THAT HAVE
WHY,CLOSE WHAT W T, IFEN
BE- L BE D TE E
IN TERMS O, WEADOT
EBGARDINTHIS, ANTHERE WE LNSD L
INDEED, BUT UKRAINE NERANTEES.NT
ER RIS
EVYINGE ETEN T
NEEK.ALL WE'RE SAYINGTE U TIM I
COMPLETE THIDISTANCEE  IYE YOU D
THISHUMAN VES OF UKRANLL US,IS I
FAIR TO TH  SKING THE
GUARANTEES.
THAYWEEST  THESECURITY GUARANTE.
>>O I'M GETTING OLD I ASK YOU --
ND, I TTACK.
>>US BE.
T
THAT'S -- IT D'TSO
I HAVEF I TALK
UNDERSTANHEVERY BEGINNING, BU
E SOME VERY IMPORTANT IN
>> WHAT I WA T
WHNTIDENT, TS ITS LLIGENCE, YOI
PUTIN'S INTE H
CAPABILITYHITEIO WILL INSIDE TOs
RUSSI
THAT'S WHY I PROSEEET.TH[ LAUGH]
N ATE -- YOU E LLT
GO. A
>> NO,O,OUE D.FR
>> Translator: WELY WILL BE VER.
I'M SURER
THIS IS ST MY E
SOLDIE A HERE IS RTANT, AND I W
MORNING  UKRAINEAN